really wish I had a pirate hat for this
review but you can't have everything yo
ho ho me hearties welcome to this review
of the curse of the black spot the
second story third episode of a series
six so coming off of the the implanting
of the mystery around the doctor died
can we stop it can it be prevented now
we have a version of the dargah doesn't
know he's gonna die can amy get away
with not telling him who's this woman
with the eyepatch you were seeing all
this stuff going on in let's go up and
have a pirate adventure for a little bit
now here's the thing I have a tendency
to point out and complain when an
episode is largely filler however there
are times when the kinds of filler that
it is just appeal to me and that's
pretty much the case here I'm a sucker
for pirates I've always been a sucker
for pirates and I have a lot of fun with
this episode even though I don't think
there is very much substantive to it I
just enjoy it and I enjoy it despite the
fact that it does another thing that I
really generally don't care for and I
tend to rip into the show over which is
oh this this being the supernatural folk
tale being thing of legend the siren
outweigh its aliens because of course it
is because it's always aliens but for
some reason it doesn't bother me and
this one nearly as much as it does in
most other cases and I think as odd and
somewhat tenuous as the explanation
is there is a reason for why this
artificial intelligence behaves in this
way so like if you go back to something
like say tooth and claw they just wanted
a werewolf and there's really no reason
for the monster to be a werewolf as
opposed to literally anything else
same with vampires in Venice for that
matter there's really no reason for it
to be vampires as opposed to merely
anything else that it could have been
here there is an act once we get the
explanation of what the siren is which
is a medical program there is a reason
that it looks human despite being alien
because this truck it's it's currently
trying to resuscitate you meant so it's
trying to appear as calming to them as
possible there's a reason it's all
hypnotic about them because it's based
it's singing is basically anesthetize in
people and and additions that it makes
sense that it's going after people with
wounds and go it's going oh you're in
trouble I'll help you the end I can look
at the way it behaves and see how it
links up with a legend but also makes
sense it's not just a complete and utter
coincidence it is that too but all these
things exist for a reason outside of the
coincidence there is a justification for
them being there and sometimes and
that's all I need
and I dig that here so between the fact
that there's pirates and I don't get
bothered by the folklore creature
turning out to be aliens nearly as much
as I do normally and there's some really
funny lines from Smith especially in
this we got Hugh Bonneville as a pirate
which I'm also a sucker for because I
mean grant I think it was after that it
was after this but like he was also the
the the pirate leader in galavant so
like he just him as a pirate I really
like I like that Henry Avery is an
actual historical pirate so they went
with an actual historical pirate but not
like one of the name
that everybody knows like freedom
Blackbeard or Captain Kidd or what have
you like no then like I didn't know it's
not about this guy but I've looked into
him since this episode aired he was
nifty cool dude nice call I dig it again
I normally don't like the historical
figure being brought into the story but
I like it here because it's somebody who
I didn't feel like I already knew
everything about and that was kind of
neat and kind of cool but it just it's
just a case of the things lining up and
just happening to press sort of my happy
places in a few ways and smoothing over
that sounded dirty when I said that and
since moving over things that might
normally bother me it just happens to
line up well for me does that make this
a stellar and excellent episode well no
but it does make it on the much more
enjoyable end of filler which is
obviously what it is at the end of the
day it is unfortunately also sort of the
kick off of the repeated killing a
boring it's not the first time he dies
but when we first first see him die in
Amy's choice that is a case where we
already knew going in we were dealing
with a multiple reality situation and it
was distinctly possible that the worry
we just saw dive was not the real Rory
we knew that just from the initial set
up so I don't even really count that one
then he did die proper and cold-blood
the second half of the Silurian
two-parter from the previous C series
and there was weight to that Karen
Gillan especially sold that really
really well but then this kicks off the
start of let's kill Rory over and over
and over and over again now you want to
be technical he had a death fake out
last episode too but so did Amy and so
did River so like that was part of a
trifecta here on his own death faked out
twice two times because first he gets
taken by the siren and then he nearly
drowned while he does drown effectively
and then
amy has to resuscitate him and knowing
how much it became a oh my god they
killed Rory kind of thing I'm annoyed
seeing that you know kicking off a sign
from Bonneville the supporting actors
are okay they're not great which is
unfortunate because it's it's a
collective and established dynamic and I
usually like that when it can work very
well it really worked well in things
like the impossible plan on the Satan
pit and the waters of Mars where we have
this group with an established rapport
that the doctor comes in on but the
other actors don't I mean part of is the
characters don't get a ton to do but
there just isn't things aren't quite
clicking with the other guest actors
which is kind of a shame because I
normally I think ensemble cast is one of
the inherent strengths of a pirate story
you get a lot of really interesting
characters and get to see how they
bounce off each other but not really a
play here so there's that aside from
that um yeah I just I just enjoy this
one I I really do just kind of like this
oh there's a moment I really love it the
men towards the beginning when amy gets
basically sent below decks because they
think she'll she's docile and they can
just use her for labour and she finds a
sword cool but she also sees a jacket
and a hat and like again does bury Amy I
love that she takes that it's not like a
ton of time but she takes the extra 30
seconds to wear the coat in the Hat and
really get into the swing of things in
terms of having fun on a pirate ship and
rescuing the doctor and Rory I love that
she does that that just it just makes me
very happy
I feel like this revisiting these is
kind of reignited my love for Amy and
not like I ever forgot that I liked Amy
or anything like that but I think it had
kind of faded just how much I really do
enjoy Amy I enjoy her a lot especially
would be overall die
amicus group but like I said it is
filler I know it's not much more than
that oh the other thing worth
highlighting for me is the music because
part of what I really like about pirate
stories in pirate movies is pirate
inspired music I like the ivory the
soundtrack to the first Pirates of the
Caribbean movie curse of the Black Pearl
I one of my all-time favorite
soundtracks I love that thing
and this reminded me of that I think
this has got really good music on top of
everything else
so yes it's filler but it's pirate
filler which automatically makes it
better filler than your average everyday
filler and I've now set filler so many
times I should have made a drinking game
out of it you would all be so wasted
right now and then you'd probably be all
the more likely to listen to me when I
say if you have thoughts you should drop
something down in the comments and we'll
talk about it and hit the like and the
subscribe and share this around and
support me on patreon maybe I'll try
that next time oh well we'll see I
probably won't even remember because
yeah that's my brain in any case folks
thanks so much for stopping in all that
stuff is down below that I mentioned
click on things it'll do stuff or don't
you don't have to I don't have the Hat
so I'm not a captain I can't order you
around cuz you're the council and I'm
just running the meetings so until next
time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]